What is your --
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)
What is your connection to dance?
Do you love the ballet,
or maybe you watch
those dance competitions on television?
Or did you jump into the hora
at that bar mitzvah one time?
I want you to reconsider
your connection to dance,
because I believe it to be
a simple and successful way
of accessing happiness within.
What do you need to participate?
Virtually nothing ...
but your will to explore
and have a little fun.
No music,
no partner required.
When I choreograph for film,
television and commercials,
I often generate moves
that are based on the human experience.
I take these moves,
I string them together,
twist and play with their pace,
in order to create more meaningful work.
Let me show you what I mean.
Here's a music video, "Chandelier,"
that I choreographed for Sia,
featuring the incredible dancer
Maddie Ziegler.
("Chandelier" by Sia)
(Lyrics) Won’t open my eyes
Keep my glass full until morning light
Because I'm just holding on for tonight
Help me, I'm holding on for dear life
Won't look down, won't open my eyes
Keep my glass full until morning light
Because I'm just holding on for tonight
On for tonight
Sun is up
Ryan Heffington: Now, let's play
that video one more time.
And I want to show you
what inspired those moves.
You may be surprised
at how rudimentary the sources are.
(No music)
RH: And fork, fork, fork,
stab it in the wall,
toss it and pass out,
come to
and look;
Charlie Chaplin, Charlie Chaplin,
cockroach up the wall,
clean your mustache,
a possum, sink ...
Is it time for lunch yet?
(Laughter)
Thanks.
(Applause)
See, even a cute little cockroach
can inspire a dance move.
But it really is that easy.
And, look ...
Most people can't dance like Maddie,
including myself.
And that's the point.
We all have our own
beautiful ways of moving,
and this is worth celebrating.
It’s time to extract the judgment
out of our dance experience
and set free the preconceived notion
of what "good" dance is.
And instead ...
find out how your own body loves to move,
and find out that inner rhythm
that feels so good.
Think more body ...
less critique.
So you may ask, "Well, how do I access
or unlock this dance magic?"
Well, once you have the perspective
that life is dance,
yeah?
You'll begin to see dance
everywhere around you, all day long,
like I do.
Like now.
Witness how you're sitting in front of me.
Your posture.
Are both feet grounded?
Is one leg crossed over the other?
Where are your hands placed?
Or envision ...
a parent rocking their child.
It's a playful flourish, right?
Tying your shoe.
A grand gesture.
Drinking a glass of water.
The stylized head release.
So check out this proof of concept.
In the first week of the worldwide
lockdown in March 2020,
I decided to teach this online
follow-along dance class called SWEATFEST.
I was hoping --
(Cheers and applause)
I was hoping that a couple
of friends would join in,
but over the course
of the next couple of weeks,
tens of thousands of people
from all over the world
joined SWEATFEST ...
turning our collective isolation
into a worldwide community.
It was absolutely beautiful.
People checked their critical minds
and really unleashed that joy from within,
doing these goofy dance moves,
while the world was in disarray.
Take a look.
(Music)
(Music ends)
(Laughs)
Who would have guessed
that moves like the Pretty Pony
and the Bob Ross ...
would be so life-changing.
(Laughter)
So, I've been a student
of dance for 42 years.
My relationship with the art form
runs deep and quite intimate.
This helped me through trauma,
it has paid my rent,
but most of all, it's been
an unfaltering joy in my life.
And that's why I'm here.
Because I believe
there's more joy for you,
only steps away,
via simple and rudimentary moves
that you already know.
So, I'd love to invite you
to be your own choreographer.
Grab your kids or go solo,
and let fun and laughter push
the boundaries of ridiculousness.
Who knows?
Maybe brushing your teeth
or whisking up mac and cheese
will become your new favorite dance move.
And once you have a dance move
or two or three or four under your belt,
respectfully call yourself a dancer ...
because you've earned it --
and share those moves and that happiness
with those around you,
because a world of more dance
is a world of more joy.
(Music)
(Music stops)
(Lyrics) Sit down and begin playing.
If you feel good
about yourself and the world,
it will show in your painting,
and all these little things will happen.
(Music continues)
(Music ends)
(Cheers and applause)
RH: Thank you.
(Cheers and applause continue)